i think we're all sick of this [ __ ]  though i mean the corona is kind of like  the check engine light you know when you  first hear about you're like damn this  is terrifying and after a while you're  like [ __ ] i gotta get to work  this is too much  yeah  some people didn't buy it though my  uncle he looks at corona like it's the  tooth fairy he's like i know this is all  made up but i'll take the free money  [Laughter]  [Music]  it's a crazy country we live in you know  eventually all this will be over you  know it's something to look forward to  eventually this will all be over  you know the pandemic will end the  police brutality will end and then we'll  be right back to school shootings you  know  what a  what a nation